Mira pues lo que sabemos es que algunos
científicos creen efectivamente que los
que los fenómenos del niño pueden
volverse más intensos y más frecuentes
como resultado del cambio climático pero
no está 100% claro exactamente como
interactúa el niño con el cambio
climático Es probable que los impactos
relacionados con con el niño y la niña
en términos de eventos
climáticos extremos Eso sí sin duda y
precisamente de eso quería hablarles
está destinado el continente americano y
concretamente quiero preguntarle por
Suramérica a ver cada vez fenómenos más
extremos
el cambio el modelo de cambio climático
lo que estamos viendo Es lo que lo que
estamos experimentando ya es Es que sí y
especialmente el sur global el sur
global se sabe que tiene los efectos más
pesados de del cambio climático Entonces
eso eso habla de más incendios Huracanes
lluvias fuertes no estamos viendo
condiciones extremas en todo el mundo
pero especialmente en el cursor global
un ejemplo serían los los incendios que
se ven en en el Amazonas por ejemplo no
un lugar donde es condiciones extremas
pluvialmente extremo y ahora Estamos
viendo
incendios forestales en las zonas
tremendos y
que son obviamente pésimos para la salud
del ecosistema y el cambio climático
bueno hablaba usted de los incendios en
el Amazonas estábamos viendo también los
incendios de Canadá el año pasado
también Vimos una temporada fuerte de
incendios en Europa en Estados Unidos
podremos ver también en Un verano de
muchos juegos este año porque viene de
un invierno especialmente nivoso en las
montañas rocosas
y pluvial hubieron lluvias
extremadamente fuertes en en sobre todo
en el en las zonas de California ahora
bien
predecir Es difícil lo que podemos saber
es que lo que podemos decir es que
generalmente estamos viendo climas más
extremos en nuestras temporadas y que el
sur oeste de Estados Unidos está
rompiendo récord seguidos de incendios
forestales Entonces
lo importante es saber que esto está
pasando ya y estar listos estar
preparados no estos incendios forestales
son un ejemplo más de los impactos de
del camento del calentamiento global